Feud alerts Maksim Chmerkovskiy skipped
Dancing with the Stars on Monday night
now we're breaking down why it's only
week three of the ABC competition but
drama is already going down after Tom
Bergeron dedicated Monday's episode to
those affected by the Las Vegas shooting
co-host Erin Andrews informed the
audience that one pro dancer wouldn't be
taking the stage max is dealing with a
personal issue so Allen is stepping in
and dancing with Vanessa tonight now
sources confirmed to ET that max didn't
perform because of an ongoing conflict
with the former Total Request Live host
quote they were acting like they had
great chemistry when really they were
just faking it to seem more likable to
the fans the source adds that things got
heated between the two this week quote
he's being a brat it was nothing
specific just little disagreements that
escalated but don't expect the Ukrainian
dancer to sit out the show again the
source tells ET quote he'll have to put
his ego aside because there are
contracts involved it's very humbling as
for Vanessa she seems to be taking the
high road max can't be here to sleep
on Monday she shared a pic from last
night's performance on Instagram I'm
very excited writing quote I can't wait
to get started tomorrow with at Maxim C
on week four and a spokesperson for the
show tells et max and Vanessa will be
dancing together on next week's show